what are we doing standing here while
you record this behind-the-scenes
interview Carmichael you know what we're
doing so this is cat dog kung fu or cat
video come foo or cat vs. dog kung fu we
haven't exactly decided yet I think this
was originally Jake's idea he really
wanted to do some sort of like kung fu
video yeah this idea was really Sam
gorski's idea and Sam was sitting there
on his computer like facing away like
not really paying attention it was like
do just have cat and dog fighting rad
let's do it
if you haven't seen by now Sam and a car
in Detroit should be moving so we're
here continuing to make video games I
said that wrong
well let's have Jake just lower a little
bit perfect I think first off we're not
fooling anyone we know that everyone's
gonna look at these cautions be like
that's a person in a costume with an
animal head cop-con to their head
everyone's gonna know that immediately
so I don't know if that's a bad thing
it's just kind of like the nature of
what this is we drew inspiration from
this video called dragon baby by the
legendary Patrick boy even obeah was
pretty good it was I was I was impressed
actually
speak speak then came Cory the cat
Cory the cat is a cat she hates being
held for longer than she wants to be
held for and she doesn't care about your
eye line up down great
Bovie we actually got specific shots
moving him like we could for each
individual shot but with Cory on the
other hand we're just kind of getting a
bunch of random stuff hopefully some of
that will work so naturally we have a
little dog we have a little cat and they
should fight each other or as I going to
tent the guys from the EMC monkeys
develop the choreography for this -
we've worked with plenty of times before
they're very good friends of ours we had
three different sequences for each
section of the fight this long like
10-minute fight we boiled that down to
about like a minute and a half to
actually film and it was really cool to
see the guys develop things from nothing
all the way into a fully developed
choreographed fight scene perhaps like
use his momentum to carry him through so
that he stumbles backwards oh I didn't
jump back yeah you go back again I
feeling another you a dog swing kind of
thing yeah perfect yeah that'd be great
yes so the costumes are cool because
we're like we're shooting this video in
a week and we don't have any costumes
hey man zzzz oh here's one right here
this is an under suit that has all of
these different colors of bird tacked
onto it hand sewn onto it to recreate
Cory the cat's colors really proud of
the back
you're not red no yes okay I want to
change we've got a cute tail I don't
quite think OB understood but Cory was
terrified she took one look at that
costume was like bah
okay so effects wise this was not
exactly challenging but it's certainly
very tricky tricky in the sense that you
have to get the camera perspective right
for filming the actual fighters on the
green screen and then you have to get
the motion right of the animals and
frame by frame keyframe the position and
rotation of that head to match there
were some shots where the collars were
visible for the majority of the shot and
we're able to track that in mocha but
most of this was literally just hand
tracked frame by frame so now we have
our green screen fighters we have our
green screen animals now we have to get
a background plate and that is basically
what the footage is
the actors right if these people are
like six feet tall and we're gonna
shrink them down to like two and a half
feet it's like so seven feet matching
perspective is really important that
aspect because science which brings us
to the final step which is the camera
shake and After Effects using a third
order magnitude camera shake chaos sort
of thing I made a tutorial for that in
last week's video on the same anikó
channel link right here what we did was
we took one of those like Green Wharf
suits and they come with like these
little head masks they just took that I
chopped a hole in the top and put two
holes and like where the eyes are and it
made it a perfect like t-shirt for an
animal at least Obie was okay with it
Cory is like good hands coming out of
the sleeves and just scratching you I
still have cuts and so it was really
funny to have to sit in a green-screen
Matt suit with a mask on holding a cat
with a green-screen shirt on well she
was sitting there basically just
complaining to death about the fact that
she was being held it was kind of sad it
was kind of funny a lot of mixed
emotions
oh you Anne yes she has been in many
things she was in our powered up video
she was in video game high school sure I
was great she was really easy to work
with she knew exactly what we're trying
to do from the door take a couple steps
you see and react so to see that pull
that and you can't react like surprised
in it before okay so she's such like a
talented actress it's like uh hey we
only need you for like one shot okay
with that she's like yeah totally as
long as I get to hang out with Obi is an
integration with Microsoft Surface so it
is really fun to have a ridiculous
amount of you know unique creative
control on a integration like this with
Microsoft they let us literally chop off
cat and dog heads put them on some
people in costumes and have them tear of
a house and the suburbs book is pretty
cool I ran after effects on it on in
tablet mode didn't think I'd be able to
do that at all if I can just like sit
next to a tree just like watching the
sunset be like rotoscope hey Carmichael
is this is enough light so a Carmichael
who's holding the camera right now did
all the sound design for this and a
fantastic sound collection of like
really you
punches really makes the video come
together he used the sound design pack
from film riot we are huge fans of them
and they have this sale going on how
much of their stuff so I'd highly
recommend checking it out well represent
off right now big sale I don't know how
long I last so get on it while you can
highly recommend it the really really
quality sound packs I just want this
video to be done thanks for watching
guys hope to tune in next week for a
cool Christmas video so Carmichael's
gonna do sound for this at some point
because we're filming this behind the
scenes before doing the sound cuz he
does like three jobs and he does Alden
once upon a time a little tiny village
not too far away there was a kid named
Michael car he was a silly little boy
only had one eye and no teeth